you
please be seated
good morning my name is Bill rickard and
along with Jack Hyland we are the
co-chairs of the board of trustees of
Teachers College and I have the honor of
officially opening today's ceremony on
behalf of the entire Teachers College
community I welcome you to the 2011
masters commencement convocation you're
all brave to be here today it's my great
pleasure now to introduce the president
of Teachers College susan h Furman good
morning welcome to convocation at
Teachers College today a feeling of joy
which poet friedrich schiller described
as a bright spark of divinity permeates
this magnificent Cathedral joy fills the
hearts of those unsung heroes who bore
so many sacrifices to make it to this
day the parents partners and children of
our graduates we thank
joy touches the hearts of tc's faculty
and staff who have mentored nudge and
nourished our students on their critical
paths all the way to earning their
degrees thank you and joy surely dwells
in the hearts of our graduates who have
tested their ideas and pursued their
dreams in tc's laboratory of knowledge
and I am overjoyed to warmly welcome our
graduates into tc's alumni Fellowship of
scholars and professionals throughout
the world congratulations well done
now don't get too comfortable we are
hardly done with you starting tomorrow
we are counting on you to join our
global network of innovative leaders in
the task of shaping the learning century
this should be your moment perhaps for
the first time in history education
shines is the coin of the realm in world
affairs and for good reason education
drives innovation and fuels productivity
it is the lifeblood of democracy and
diversity education particularly
advanced education and teaching
counseling and allied health fields lays
the foundation for public and civic
health and yet we are fighting uphill
battles together on multiple fronts to
protect this precious currency we are
fighting to reverse a nationwide high
school dropout epidemic that condemns
more than a million American teenagers a
year to lives of poverty despair and
drift we are fighting to reduce ever
widening gaps in educational opportunity
and scholastic achievement within our
country even as we simultaneously
struggle to catch up in math and science
literacy with other nations we are
fighting a global obesity epidemic fed
by a toxic brew of economic cultural and
behavioral forces the World Health
Organization estimates the global
population of obese people at 300
million roughly the equivalent of the
entire population of the United States
we are fighting to scam a rising tide of
ridicule suspicion and anger aimed at
the very people on the front lines who
are best prepared to tackle and solve
society's toughest problems educated
professionals like you and me in
particular teachers leaders and teacher
educators have been unfairly blamed and
often viciously attacked for the
failures of the system itself a system
that fails to distribute an allocate
resource
is equitably and efficiently a system
that doesn't use existing policy levers
to strengthen weak schools and chooses
instead to tar all public schools with
the same rhetorical brush and much of
the public discussion on education has
failed to address or even recognize the
complexity of the challenges we face
instead we get large servings of
simplistic rhetoric that embraces
marginal reforms and experiments as
panaceas when we should be developing
new approaches that can be leveraged
into broad scale achievement and
approved it simply put we cannot bicker
and blame our way to success we can and
should put our heads together pull our
perspectives and our specialized areas
of expertise and craft powerful and
enduring solutions to the challenges
facing our nation and world the talent
for blending new ideas with well granted
knowledge in order to produce effective
new educational strategies and methods
is embedded in TCS DNA it sparked
educational pioneers such as James
Russell John Dewey Edward Thorndike
Margaret Mead and others to explore new
insights into human development and to
develop revenue revolutionary modalities
of teaching and learning through
collaboration and innovation the modern
k-12 classroom was born here as was the
modern college of education itself
social studies education began here as
did special education the study of
gifted children was born and shaped TC
as well meanwhile tc's dynamic
partnerships with local schools in
Harlem and communities throughout the
world has and will enabled us to promote
equity and transform urban education at
a time of scarce resources and through
your leadership in the vanguard of
collaboration and
station tc's power to shape the learning
century will know no bounds masters
graduate Shannon Bishop is hoping to
take her place in the vanguard of
learning in South Africa
yay Shannon she is taking the tools and
tech-savvy TC gave her to help
youngsters learn English as a second
language in a country where black
children are exposed to half as many as
many as a half a dozen languages and
dialects she plans to establish an
after-school academic center in Cape
Town that will use multimedia and
advanced storytelling techniques in
order to bridge the digital and language
divide in South Africa closer to home
Maria hinkson was working as an
accountant when a chance encounter with
a TC trained speech pathologist who was
helping one of her children changed her
life she enrolled in tc's program which
sent her to Africa to work with a cleft
palate team in Ghana now as a freshly
minted speech pathologist Maria is ready
to do her part to help New York City do
a better job responding to children with
speech and linguistic issues right now
she says when kids have speech issues
that actually are linguistic in origin
they are often tracked into ESL or
otherwise given in appropriate therapy
or no help at all I expect Maria to
become a formidable advocate and force
for educational change in the year ahead
yay Maria
all our graduates could not have picked
a better time to bring their TC
education to bear on the most
challenging issues of the day indeed
this is a fabulous time for this group
of Future Leaders to be entering the
world of government academia health
professions or the classrooms with a
degree from teachers college we're on
the verge of major breakthroughs in
neuro and cognitive science and
astonishing advances in digital
technology that can increase the
learning of all young and old rich and
poor alike long ago Emerson told a room
full of Future Leaders much like
yourselves this time like all times is a
very good one if we but know what to do
with it graduates this is your time your
moment for shaping the learning century
keep adding to the knowledge that you
helped advance at EC draw on the wealth
of life-changing experiences you enjoyed
here build on the friendships you made
here and by all means make your time the
very best of times for us all thank you
we have now reached the moment should
present the Teachers College medal for
distinguished service the highest honor
the College bestows we honor those
extraordinary women and men whose lives
work has advanced the cause of education
while upholding tc's core mission to
foster excellence and equity in the
fields we serve the Distinguished
Service Medal has been given in past
years to Archbishop Desmond Tutu Coretta
Scott King senator George Mitchell Pete
Seeger Tom Sobel Lee Shulman Gail
Collins Spike Lee and many others this
year our medalists our eminent exemplars
former New York Times columnist and
author Bob Herbert Baltimore City
Schools CEO dr. andres alonso and
stanford professor education scholar and
former TC faculty member dr. Linda
darling-hammond mr. Herbert will receive
his medal at this afternoon's master
ceremony and dr. darling-hammond will
receive her medal tomorrow at the
doctoral hooding ceremony here to
present dr. alonza with his medal is our
provost and dean dr. thomas james
Thank You president Furman it is my
pleasure to introduce dr. Jeffrey hennig
professor of political science and
education he also chairs our newly
created Department of Education Policy
and social analysis dr. Hennig will
present our medalist recipient dr.
andres Alonso
andrez Alonso you have often recalled
how on your first day as a special
education teacher at a school for
emotionally disturbed children you
contemplated a sign on the principal's
wall that said the kids come as is by
changing virtually every other variable
and broken schools you have transformed
the lives of thousands of children whom
society has written off it was with that
mission that at age 29 you left a
promising law career to teach in Newark
one of the nation's most troubled school
districts over the next decade you
visited children in their homes assisted
drug-addicted parents and even adopted a
student as your own son yet you hunger
to achieve reform in a far broader scale
you found the opportunity to do so as
CEO of schools in Baltimore we're more
than four-fifths of all students live in
poverty and where the school system has
parentally defied reform under your
leadership students across all
categories achieve their highest ever
outcomes on state exams highest ever
graduation rate and lowest ever dropout
rates for the first time ever elementary
and high school students and all
subgroups have made adequate yearly
progress parent Baltimore's dropout rate
has since fallen by half and for the
first time in decades the city's public
school system is gaining students
instead of losing them your success
certainly stems in part from the many
brilliant tactical moves you have made
but it also derives from your own near
superhuman commitment of energy time and
love and your insistence on the same
from all in your employ
dr. Alonzo one of your own deputies has
said if he can't do it no one will ever
do it we will never have a
superintendent of this caliber again
fortunately every indicator is that
beyond succeeding you will ultimately
demonstrate beyond all doubt that
American public schools not only can be
saved but are eminently worth saving for
that perhaps more than your many other
remarkable accomplishments we are proud
to present you with the teacher's
college medal for distinguished service
what a setting it's hard in this setting
to obey FDR's dictum that a speech
should be all about being short being
sincere and being seated so I will
definitely hit the mark with the second
one because this is a very personal to
me so good morning graduates faculty
honored guests families and friends let
me first congratulate all of you the
graduates to believe in a child is to
believe in the future Henry James once
said you're here because you believe in
the future in this time when educators
are often castigated for our share
failing and educating many children to
their potential we need to continually
point out that you are in the arena you
believe you are dedicating your lives to
improving the lives of children 25 years
ago I change course in my career and
became an educator it has been the
single most important and right decision
in my life in the schools where I have
taught and led the act of educating
children is often a struggle against
many things that belie are believing
children you believe in you surf I
salute you as a brother in arms I want
to now tell you how honored and humbled
I am by this medal because I came to be
an educator after having practice law I
was always a learner first there are so
many people who taught me and inspire me
who are far more deserving than I am of
receiving this recognition I think of my
first principle or some of the teachers
who taught with me in my first school
who helped calibrate my moral compass or
superintendents who later helped channel
my contrarian impulses with the example
of their efforts their patients to do
good things in their communities they
are responsible for what I have done
right this honor also reminds me that I
am getting old i am now 32 years removed
from receiving my Bachelor degree at
this very same campus and a day in May I
remember like yesterday I hope you
remember it in the same way for
yourselves 30 years from now
paraphrasing st. Augustine why did my
youth leave me and if it did since it's
still with me where did it go that boy
who arrived at Columbia roughly 35 years
ago lives in every action I take today
my parents were there then and are here
again today I have to say again how
proud I am to be before you today that
boy was shaped by having grown up in a
small town in Cuba during the 60s a time
of social upheaval and revolution and by
the experience of having to physically
leave my childhood behind it was shaped
by a tightly knit family and community
where my parents were my first teachers
I've told the story before of receiving
at the age of six before her I had ever
gone to school a birthday gift of four
books brand-new I wonder in a place
where books were hard to find outside of
a small public library each book
containing possibilities in each
communicating an enormous belief about
what my future contained one was a white
hardcover a bridge version of The Three
Musketeers
another was a historical novel about a
sailor in Magellan's quest to
circumnavigate the world the other two
were moral fictions about adolescents in
parochial schools in England and France
how I remember them today conveys the
importance they had in my life learning
matter this Christmas through the wonder
of the web I hunted down one of them and
i use bookshop in toledo spain and
reread it it was worth the effort the
book was I grew as great as I remember
it has shaped me America was then my
teacher far too often the discussion of
immigrant students starts with a notion
of a deficit how wrong that is how much
does it miss the experience of the child
assimilating by osmosis regardless of
what schools do and by intention when
it's done right not simply a second
language in school matters but an entire
system of signs a new culture where
every behavior is a lesson I was lucky I
felt then and still feel now that in my
first American schools across the Hudson
in Union City New Jersey I fell into a
stream of great expectations that
carried me here everything I have done
as an educator once I became a teacher
has been about ensuring that every
student under my watch can swim in that
same stream at the time I thought I
became a teacher almost by accident it's
clear to me now that it was meant to be
I had gone to Harvard Law School I'd
practice law here in New York City but
something known in me perhaps the words
from Pablo Neruda spelled in a pennant
my father had once given me algun dia en
cualquier parte en cualquier lugar in
defective la mente de encontrar a SATA
mismo yessuh solo ESO puede ser la mas
feliz 0 la masa Marga de tus auras
someday
anywhere anyplace you will inevitably
find yourself and that and only that
will be the happiest or bitterest of
your hours I met my hour I am happy to
say now as soon as I began to teach at a
school for emotionally disturbed
adolescents in Newark New Jersey those
kids those parents those teachers
reposition my world all people the great
Cuban poet Jose Marti ones wrote when
they arrived on earth have a right to be
educated and then in return they have
the obligation to educate others the
obligation for me was not a burden it
was another gift my first day as a
teacher at the samuel l berliner school
in north as you refer I read a sign at
the back of the main office that said
the kids come assist they are not made
to order we taught kids whom schools had
failed whose family struggled to raise
them but they had enormous strength they
often showed huge moral sense and they
needed that moral sense in ways that I
had never needed at the same age and we
could not reach them without thinking of
reaching their families as well
respectful the kids meant respect for
the people they loved a quarter century
century later I am still using the
lessons of those first days the kids
come as this we cannot change our
schools without engaging the kids and
their families as partners the work is
about making everyone responsible for
what happens with kids just as a class
has to be about every student the school
system is only as good as this week of
school today I lead a school system
where the overwhelming majority of my
students live in poverty just like those
first kids I taught we face enormous
challenges but have made great progress
we have cut our dropout rate by more
than half in three years almost sixty
percent among african-american
male youth I do a job that some people
think undoable I was the seventh
superintendent in 10 years when I took
the job and now after four years and I
always have to laugh or smile when i say
this i have the longest superintendent
tenure in baltimore in almost two
decades but the job is exhilarating
because we are the fulcrum of everything
good that can happen in the city we
touch every day not only more than
80,000 kids but through them their
families their communities and every
social institution that responds to them
nothing else can equal that span the
opportunities far exceed the challenges
despite the way that's where that some
people still talk about urban schools we
have done this in an unusual way by
adopting the strategy so the so-called
new education reform movements we
rethink school models we closed
low-performing schools we expand choice
for example but also by putting a lot of
focus on working with communities and
partners around the needs of individual
students and about rethinking the
relationship of the community setting to
the school we have tried extraordinarily
hard to work with teachers around
redefining what needs to happen in our
classrooms and schools we have given
hope to the city about what is possible
for the first time in decades and Roman
has increased for three consecutive
years our results are encouraging but
everything feels fragile we try hard to
communicate confidence in our success
but we know that every setback means we
go back to the bottom of the hill again
when I reflect on the work we have done
in Baltimore I can only conclude that
the biggest obstacle over time has been
a lack of political will and
accountability for kids that can only be
explained by a lack of belief in the
family's poor black and white
surf how is the dropout rate in our
large cities tolerated if we value kids
communities have the graduation and
dropout and college at them attainment
rates that they want unfortunately
educators too often engage in
internecine fights that erode the
political will needed to ensure what is
necessary and possible in schools we
have managed to avoid these fights in
Baltimore and that has allowed us to
focus on fundamental questions of
responsibility and unfundamentalism how
do we know it encourage it develop it
and spread it what is good learning same
questions please finally finally we are
there how do we make everyone inside and
outside the school respond to the need
of every child why I say all the time
what is the actionable item if it's not
about the people around the table around
what the people around the table can do
in relationship to those questions we
are off target so I am coming to the end
of this acceptance having shied away I
hope from grand abstract pronouncements
and having grounded some of my
observations in memory and experience
each of you will bring your own world
and your own ineluctable self to a
classroom and a group of kids and
families and other teachers or to a
problem of practice and education in a
role that will impact what other people
in this room are doing in other
classrooms with their own kids and what
I want very badly to communicate is that
you're going to need to be true to your
essential self on behalf of yourself and
your students and yet remain open to
what others will teach you especially
the kids and families you serve and be
willing to put and leave skin in the
game to make certain that things happen
that are often very hard to accomplish
given the condition
of our schools and communities and do
that without becoming cynical or
learning to blame others for the
inevitable defeat along the way and
while you deserve huge praise in
choosing to do this work that we do you
will gain ever greater rewards because
what you do will be moral and great in
ways that no other profession can be to
educate in like a good now or cuban boy
i need to finish by quoting Marty again
is to give people the keys of the world
which our independence and love granting
them the ability to walk along at the
happy pace which is that of natural and
free individuals to educate is 23
congratulations oh thank you once again
this is an amazing honor come to
Baltimore we need you there thank you
I'm delighted now to present our student
speaker akela Reynolds
aquila brought the sunshine with her
when she moved from California to attend
Teachers College coming from UC Berkeley
two years ago she credits the
psychological counseling program where
she's been studying not only with
teaching her how to counsel but also
giving her insight into herself while at
TC she worked on a research team with a
professor who introduced her to
participatory action research using this
method in partnership with high school
students who were also working as
researchers alongside her she developed
a true commitment to addressing issues
of equity and access in education this
fall Aquila will be continuing her tour
of the United States by moving to
Houston to begin a doctoral program in
counseling psychology when thinking
about where she is and where she's going
aquila looks at where she came from she
thinks about the people who've helped
her to make her dream a reality
particularly her family and she calls to
mind the African proverb I am because
you are I am because you are presenting
aquila reynolds
as a child I was shy and deathly afraid
of public speaking one year I was in a
holiday program where one by one each
students at a speech now I'm sure my
parents were in the room waiting and
excitement to see me say those few words
when the spotlight was on me everyone
waited intently for me to speak my
parents at the edge of their seats but
with the mic to my mouth no words would
come out let's fast-forward 20 years or
so and anyone who knows me is still
probably surprised by my standing before
you today I'm surprised myself how did I
get here how am i standing before your
eyes living out a dream that was once my
biggest nightmare before coming to TC I
thought I was just going to learn how to
be a counselor I soon found out that I
had to learn a lot about myself before I
could help anyone else the work we all
do in our respective careers demand
self-awareness and empowerment which
includes looking at the power and
oppression that comes with each of our
identities we too must be aware of the
privilege we now have as TC graduates it
can be a badge of honor but it can also
be a barrier to those we wish to serve
if we're not attuned to some of the
meanings that are associated with it now
countless times we may have heard people
say do as I say and not as I do I know
there might be some parents who are
sinking in their chairs right now
because that might be an effective
strategy to get children to eat their
vegetables but as professionals we need
to stand for what we believe in and we
need to practice what we preach we need
to embody the spirit and legacy of TC
and its commitment to multiculturalism
and its contribution to research in
practice that recognizes the potential
of all people to be great if they have
access to resources knowledge choices
and support to nurture those talents
some children are fascinated by action
heroes like Superman spider-man and
Power Rangers I'm sure my nephew can
show you a couple of cool moves after
the ceremony
but what is a hero really the ones
outside of the Hollywood studios heroes
are people who believe strongly in a
cause and fight valiantly for what they
represent they are people who don't just
talk the talk but actually walk the walk
heroes embody the change that they
profess on this day May seventeenth in
1954 the Supreme Court handed down the
brown versus board of education decision
ending segregation in schools it began
with people who believed in their right
to have equal access to quality
education and these heroes stood up for
that right as I mentioned in my opening
I've always had a difficult time with
public speaking but despite my
reservations there was something deep
inside of me that needed to be here
don't worry mom and dad you don't have
to rush to the front to save me this
time because that holiday program was
just not my time but it did set the
stage for future challenges I always
wondered what it was that I admired
about people I saw on TV I realized that
among other things I was drawn to these
people because I saw them as brave I
admired their ability to step out in
front of audiences with the possibility
of being judged and criticized I too
wish that I could be courageous just
like them but back then I had this
belief that being brave meant being
fearless which exempt me from that
category because I had so many fears now
I realized that bravery it's not being
without fear it's actually the opposite
courage is having fear but doing
something despite that fear being brave
is not letting fear keep you back from
acting on something you believe
sometimes that means doing something
radically different like those who put
their heart and soul into fighting for
right that made it possible for me to
even stand before you today sometimes we
see things we don't like we're really
good at complaining but often let fear
keep us from doing something because we
don't want to stay
and alone TC has been a nurturing
experience because it challenged my
fears in the movie Aladdin one of the
characters talked about a diamond in the
rough there were people here who looks
beyond my shy and timid demeanor and
recognized the jewel in me the jewel
that each and every one of us possess if
only people really saw us despite the
times I doubted my own abilities I
persevered because these people helped
me recognize that on the other side
there was this evolved me that I always
wanted to be as we have seen with the
landmark Brown versus Board of Education
decision and so many other social
movements change is infectious and it
can start with just one person who
believes in something so much that they
dare to be different it is clear change
starts with you and me I challenge you
to be the living example of what it is
you believe I challenge you as Mahatma
Gandhi said to be the change in the
world you wish to see thank you
Thank You akela at this time it is our
pleasure to recognize each of our
candidates for graduation by reading
their names dr. Thomas Rock executive
director of Enrollment Services will
take on that task
good morning for many of you I had the
distinct pleasure of welcoming yo to
Teachers College when we admitted you
for some that was last year for some
others maybe the year before and for
some of you well let's just say it was a
very long time ago congratulations
nonetheless to all of you on this
amazing achievement at this time it
gives me great pleasure to read the
names of those candidates for the Master
of Arts Master of Education master of
philosophy and Master of Science degrees
at Teachers College Columbia University
all degrees will be conferred at the
Columbia University ceremony tomorrow I
will be reading the names of degree
candidates who registered to participate
in this ceremony by April 23rd this is
not the complete list of students
graduating tomorrow so rest assured if
you were cleared for graduation by the
office of the registrar and your name is
not called don't worry we're not taking
it back names of the candidates will be
read in place Lourdes Campos Nicole
Anita Cardamone Sara Marie Curie know
caroline elizabeth karti mingjie che
pantelis Haralambos qi wei chen Eunice
Chen Regina ji chang chen wei ling Lisa
Cian chen zhao nicole marie turn-offs
key Jane Chung Carolyn Elizabeth shamira
in Yun Chao Anna Hillary Choi Gus Paul
chrysin
rue you n qu Eunice yuna chun GE chun
nathan campbell Clendenin kathleen and
connolly Diana karina Cordova Melissa
Costa Casey costanzo Fiona Crawford ash
read cruise david john davis Rebecca
London Davis t on Deng Danielle
Elizabeth do bow Allison gene ital
chakra al dolly George LF three 8s
Carolyn elk sada El Montay sir andrew
and a moto Amelia Margaret app Caroline
and Felina lauren marie Philip pink
Esther flame Brian E Flanagan Elizabeth
em Fox Adria Murray from Connie Lily joy
freed Ling Joseph Gerard busca daniela
Elise jimenez gob ramen gaffer of
grace Ryan Galligan Yanina gar Berg
Alyssa Evans getzel vasiliki chanapa
less
michelle marie charlando Noel Dominique
Gibson Sharon Mikey Glaser Noah Harris
Gordon sia gato Felicity and Graham
Catherine Ennis Graham Gregory green
Rowan Leo colon gray Dennis Griffith
Nicole Sandra gun Alexandra Trent
Hamilton Claire Baiul han ji jaan hon
Patricia Jin soo han Marissa Christine
Hanson you kahari moto Sean Randall
Gardner Harris baseem Hassan Rebecca
Helen Hawkins Betsy field Hayes Emily
Marie hi Joe Carroll fini Henderson
Meredith Eleanor hill Kendra Nicole
Hurst Patricia how Queen Heron Hong
Taiwan Hong
Michael aura Sarah rose Horton Royce be
hoes Christina che james huang Timothy F
Ignacio Alana ingber Laurel Beth ingre
ham Christopher Darryl Ennis Carmen
Eleanor James Winona and Jamison Katya
Jimenez Eunice jo teri Margaret Johnson
jordan michelle jones Dane Joseph Amy
kapadia Christina V Corps Ivanov edina
Sarah Kastner Adam Paul key do Catherine
Laurette Kelly catherine marie Kennedy
Robert Edward keys Maria colleague
shahidul islam khan Emily Glassman
Sawatzky kaval hailey Kim Ji Young Kim
mean soon Jim so Jean gym Aaron he
kuykendahl Eun Sol co Jennifer co Velma
kokesh grace Poe Hyun Kong Lauren joy
konopka Linda eva kor khalas Connie quan
Eliza lamb morita Louise lang Kristen
Lawler Adam LeBeau Desmond John lean
Rebecca Lee sandra lee denise lynn
Lewandowski Jocelyn mod Theodora lift in
Zlin Owen Finch lips at Patrick Edwin
Livingstone Danielle monaco long Pamela
Lopez Union Jenny Louie erin elizabeth
Lynch Cynthia macias Kimberly Mackenzie
Teresa matey grove Julia Elise Malta
winegard allegra catherine marie no
Heather Nicole mar and shakur le masters
helaina Mary McCarthy
Caroline mccrossin Lindsay Sarah
McKeever Helen Melamed Marcel mentor
Daniel Richardson Merrick Belinda Jane
Michael mamiko Miyamoto christopher
robert Mizell mikako ma co Caroline
Westbrook more donna s more frigid
Glennon Moran ada Moscow k eco nakazawa
teruko nakajima krischell nuh volta
Jessica and nevitt Arthur mean we win
heather-marie nocte chaya novi Lakeisha
Renee odlum Brock Danielle I'll ring
febby areata Seong Joon Park Anna Lee
Patti Jo soo cheetah paw Viva John
Tiffany Maria pals are Meredith Lynn
Petrov
Abby Marie Porter Amanda pro-casino
Michelle Pushkin Anthony Joel Ruffin
yellow Katie Riley Rita ciao Wren
Stephanie riadi Joseph Dean Robbins
Goldie Robinson ktc Robinson megan
elizabeth Robinson de la Jay Rogers
Eugenio a rosa Hadassah Rubenstein she
when Janie Ruiz young Soleil tsubasa
alyssa michelle Samson Christina Maria
savar eyes Elizabeth and shade Robin
Nicole Sherman Rachel linnea Sahara Nina
sethi Jennifer Sutton megan murray
schaefer shen guannan Zachary Christian
shot gren Ichi shoe kimberly marie side
ii share ii Amanda signer davec
enhancing priya Sircar stephanie renee
smith Michael Sean so Bo gahi song
Sandra Charlotte Spaziani Edward Rafael
Stapleton Cornelia Elizabeth Maria
Stella carry on
tana stimpson megan at leotta studs
rebecca and strayer Clara Elizabeth
strother my you meet akazawa Carly tam
ling tong Cynthia Elise Toby Allison
Kathleen toca leche flan theming tryn
Evelyn truster Patti side Fred sighs oh
khuda gawah satomi suzuki Jonathan
Tunstall Andrew Seth van bacco kristin m
verena Karen vice blot Alicia ver Molly
Jason Castro days valerio Marissa Walker
Frissora Suzanne Janie low LOL Wallace
Sarah Danielle Warshaw lindsay marie
wells Adam Niklas Wemple Natalie Joan
willemsen melissa lee williams susan e
wilson Annique Jill will tow
kawai wrong at sushi yuck ouchie Emily
Elizabeth young d you yeah jing zhao yun
Joe michael anthony zimmerman shawnee
zamora will the students and the faculty
from the Department of arts and
humanities please stand and recognize
the graduates
and now the graduates from the
Department of bio behavioral sciences
Lila Barbara afshar Donna Akio wid
serdar Al Bayati nor abad a rottie
Carolyn Jennifer appel Blanca Esmeralda
are Mia Lauren Stacy Armstrong Marion
and beer secher Melissa and bid lock
Susanna Lawrence Brock emari danielle
brown Heather Michelle campo way king
john alexander s child mcdonald janelle
j cruise Eileen Dalton cahuachi Asafa
derez who neat dhaliwal Jonathan jewitt
Edwards he packed and sorry karoliina
Escobar is aza marina Fagan bomb trina
jean Felton Lyndsey Ruth Fenimore
Stephanie fine men Lauren Hillary fish
Berg Risa Fishman
Elaine yen Fong Delhi Marisol Francisco
ray noble Frederick the third Anna Maria
frontera via mon Katherine Justine
Galante Ashley gun in for lean guess
Lisette Gonzalez michael jason hadler
erica and hon I rom hawk Terry Michelle
herro Patrick Benedict Harvey Molly and
Henderson yael her scoff aureum you know
Maria margarita hinkson Michael T
Horvath Lee you loon si si xi huan
Lauren Hurwitz Farah ali hussein Allison
Elizabeth Kelleher Krista t Kenny nahai
on co Bridget Rose Krakouer Genevieve
Elizabeth leer un Lee Jae Lee Berman
Francesca lure Mia's Christina
Alexandria Moriarty Christine meri
Mulaney Tamara maritza and the parse
tech Giuliani echo Melissa hope Novello
Lily Yvette Nunez Dustin Jordan Pasiphae
Veera panko antonella / kasi Jenny
Claire portney Diana Pritzker carry Jean
saffron Allison andrs kovcs Sanchez
Patricia Santos Sarah Bethany Sawyer
Jacqueline and smiter Jennifer flourish
mirror Allison Schoenberger Sarah joy
schwarzwalder Jacob Andrew Sadek Terran
Claire Steenkamp jisu sung Francis
Fairbanks Wilson Alexander rice
Zimmerman will the students and the
faculty from the Department of bio
behavioral sciences please stand and be
recognized
and now the graduates from the
Department of counseling and clinical
psychology Maria ibadah Amanda eldorado
10 Heda a Fras Wendy Johanna a Faro
adrienne reed Allen Amanda and Alan
Julian Alexandra amante Gabriella
alvarado jasmine elizabeth alvarez erin
elizabeth anderson Ian um Maria Andrea
ariano piedra Virginia Kelly art Farah a
toot Lara Maria uneo Samuel Henry Barkin
Laura and Barsky yaakov Barton Kendall
Ross boussard
Catherine back Amanda Gail Benedetto
Nieto Ben C and chill Brianna Mackenzie
Bernardo Elizabeth Leah Berwick Adam
biak Rebecca Ilana birch Sabrina Vashti
booth Laura Vernon bragdon Tracy marine
branch Kristen Butterfield Meredith
Catherine Chapman quan we chen gho ill
watch oi Ashley collazo hayley marie
craine amy lane / co Gabriella Marie
dunker Brooke Eve dinner Anita an eel
deshpande allison marie t rienzo Amy
Susan Dineen Emily treat Distin Rachel
Emily Dreiling are
Denise Renee gibran VanDerveer Janine to
Curtis Edwards Esther Yeo Jin Ellison
Samantha Ewers rose marie elizabeth
fatale Aubrey Jean Fisher King uh ed
photo/rebecca France Sophia frenzel
Mariana fredlund Karen Jean me Garber
Michaela gets angela louise Gibbs lauren
elizabeth GC Julia Louisa goldmark
crystal de Mia Lynette gray Charlotte
Lucien griot Jennifer Sarah gutman
Alicia Olivia Harper Aaron Lynn Hanes
Jameson Haley he'll drink so verra
Hernandez sumon ho Lynn hoon to Debra
Lynn Isaac's swathi matao Yakutia
makara yvette joshua j song Jeong
Michelle Kimberly con Bob a kawaii bo
saint coco key re karada Steve kyu lee
seung yun lee Angela angie lee when
Maria Madeline latini melero Janet
Elizabeth lynelle Weeting leo nan and
leo Katherine laduca karina lozano
acquire Lindsay metric ho chi hiromi
Micucci Nikita Malikov Adriana Lourdes
Maldonado
daniele mancini patrick john ministre
Stephanie and Matthews Cara moro Rachel
aliza mayor's elizabeth kolbert mazzotta
Colleen k McElwain katie l milks Andrea
Elizabeth Milo furnas kazi mahajan
Katherine Jane Morgan Samantha J
Morgenstern Emily Louisa more rubab
naqvi Cheryl Nelson soda way Jeffrey
mark noble me limb Oh Wendy v orianna
Samuel Alma Lara Chris malice pangburn
Amy Elizabeth pakora Simone Nicole Perry
christine marie pachuco betta magdalena
pisat gah Jessica yannick Pierre
Sara Elizabeth pilgrim princess janiece
Prince Maccon ebony archaea rao Morgan
Elena Rasmus Aquila Aisha Reynolds
Lauren Dominique Christina Reynolds
Maria Katrina Pele's Rica amber Simone
Rick's Catherine Robinson David
Alexander row Hilary Roy Victoria Rucka
vets Danielle ryan craig Anthony
Sabatino Shane sub nany xbia sir fras
Nathaniel Matthew Shapiro Elise Maurice
gura dana marie sereno Deborah Jones
Sheehan elisa bath Laurel shine boga
Schneiderman Christian mackenzie-smith
Charles Everett staton
Jody Lynn Stein Lusk shamma super mony
Giovanni Armando cereal Kevin raiment
are low Shekinah Taylor luchia tokuda
Veronica tereko Alexia Tanith tabal
Megan tropea Lily Lily son amira al dad
I'm Michelle E Omer erin nicole Sadler
unka firm Timothy Valenti Elena Sophia
Vasquez
aditi vidya cigar bose haina this Mon
Andrea Suzanne Waxman Alex page Walczak
Emily Lauren wold jing wang Bianca
Danielle Williams kelly lynn williams
jollies yazici irene mine you Carolina's
echo shalna Julian jus Catherine aisa
karo Blaine Zucker will the students and
the faculty from the Department of
counseling and clinical psychology
please stand and be recognized
and now the graduates from the
Department of curriculum and teaching
and Catherine Abrams Rebecca and Abrams
Jaclyn Dana Acker you wan s on Lauren
Adair Allen laura jane anderson
Stephanie L Armstrong Amy Bader Lauren
page bells Stacey Helena Baird Bethany
Jane Barrowman Marceline Baumann
Alexandra dine beasts on croston
Jennifer Albert bets Marsha Carol Blair
Dahlia Christine bowery Sara Elizabeth
bright Shauna Francine Burke Isabella be
Butler Ellen see ohm Kentrell Michelle
Renee Carberry Tasha curdle Oh Cheryl in
fay car hub Flavia covario Louie Carlos
catio
and Catherine Chalmers Cheryl chewin way
Chi Yong Kwan Chung Heather Clarke
Lauren Amanda Clarke Alexandra clearing
shakya coals courtney lynn Connors
Elizabeth collect Cotter Vanessa
Lucrezia deja do Karen de Silva banged a
Katrina de vino Frederick d Rebecca's
Michelle Edison Cara Alyssa Iceman's
amidst Shara Rachel Eisner grinberg
Elizabeth hill and go Avery and rector s
locker Danielle foyer Rachel Michelle
thin Linton Cara Ariel Fisher Caitlin
Fitzsimmons georgeanna Lee franzblau
Carolyn Garcia guerra angel game Lindsay
Catherine Geum Andrea Gila Bertie nicole
elizabeth Maria Gobbo Catherine Gomez
Melissa Elizabeth Gonsalves Kaylee Greg
where Elizabeth Asiata Hayes Ashley gene
Hines Julie mean kun Hong
courtney elizabeth her an kimberly sooo
Hudson Sakina Jaffrey Kimberly and Jacko
Mia Lynette Johnson Christina Marie
Joseph Farah Kareem Anna kettavan
catherine marie katie jenn Jessica Kim
one me Jim Laura M king Pamela Ashley
Krantz Elizabeth crevasse head ached uh
come Bonnie Jamie be kushner shannon
marie lang sarah & Laden Kira lee kwang
yoon Lee Emily Ballard Lily Leticia
where Mary's leo Caitlin Patricia
Mahoney Jeanette Marie Marie mucci
Christopher Thomas McBride Caitlin
McCauley Carolyn McDonough laura
michelle min ring Julia Claire Miller
megan elizabeth molten Lily Anne be
Mullane christina s mun jennifer marie
marie Yuko nukka sawa anita the mayor
kimberly and nearing brittany nicole
Nelson Lena be owned Laura FIBA obv
Brittany Elizabeth oh n Cynthia Marie PT
kwela Perry anto sake parent Sheen
jennifer lynn p upon grace player Eunice
palm Julia Vanessa Ramos Rebecca celia
roth ski Conroy Richie Jennifer shilling
Alison Maurice Wars jaewon Sheldon
Elizabeth Ellen's lunker danielle rose
smith
Brent Staker Michiko sugiyama sunny Mary
Sue Andrea Jan sklar ski Sarah check
kechara lock TBD cool Charice Shante
Thomas courier Nathaniel Todd Ellen
Alexandra Campbell totten Allison and
Turner Rebecca k tines immerman henna
wadhwa Danielle Sarah wall thin so Troy
din wangchuck drew Douglas Watson Lee
carpenter web magdalena King yahwah neck
alana Wahlberg OG Audrey wang petraea
lunch omnom Judy you on Katherine
Zimmerman
will the students and the faculty from
the Department of curriculum and
teaching please stand and be recognized
and we'll all of our graduates and our
faculty please stand and be recognized
thank you and now provost James
president Fuhrman mr. ruckert mr. Hyland
trustees faculty and guests it is my
pleasure as provost of the college to
present you the masters candidates from
teachers college please hold your
applause until all the candidates have
been recognized with those receiving the
Masters of Arts please stand be
recognized and remain standing with
those receiving the masters of science
please stand be recognized and remain
standing with those receiving the
masters of philosophy stand be
recognized and remain standing and with
those receiving the Masters of Education
please stand be recognized and remain
standing president Furman I ask that you
recommend these students for the
granting of their masters degree
tomorrow morning in the Columbia
University commencement exercises
please be seated
I'm Robert wine trail president of the
Teachers College Alumni Association it's
with great pleasure that I formally
welcome you our newest alumni into our
community you are joining a body of some
90,000 professionals from all our
departments and programs in all walks of
life at all stages of careers who have
made a significant mark in the world
they have done so because of their
intelligence sensitivity drive knowledge
experience and wisdom they have also
done so because of the people like the
ones around you today family friends
teachers administrators trustees
benefactors and fellow alumni
representing our alumni I am here to
tell you how valuable participation in
our association can be we are colleagues
and collaborators supporters and
challengers advisors and networkers and
what holds us all together is our alma
mater if your time here with anything
like mine you experience moments of
puzzlement angst and weariness along
with insight inspiration and laughter
and many of you have developed what will
be lifelong friendships if your future
time here is anything like mine I can
assure you that your continued
connection to TC will continue to bring
you in sight inspiration laughter and
friendships right now I know that your
focus is and should be on your
work and careers you are destined to do
important things in education
development health care and
organizations but please know that you
have a home and rich community in TC
which you can tap into physically and
virtually your fellow alumni along with
all the people here that make Teachers
College special wish you all the best in
your endeavors and we hope we have the
opportunity to join you along the way
good morning I am Jack Highland co-chair
the board of trustees on behalf of all
of the trustees of Teachers College I
would like to congratulate each of you
on your very significant achievement we
thank you your families and friends for
joining with us the faculty and staff of
Teachers College to recognize all of you
our masters candidates of the class of
please join us for some light
refreshments on the first and second
floors of zankel building and in Russell
courtyard where you may be interested to
know there is a tent for all of those
who are not students would you please
remain in your seats until our students
have left thank you and once again
congratulations